you were on the road all the time and I
would think it would start to drive you
a little crazy oh no I love it I love it
you love it you love the life of being
in hotels I love I love stand-ups
different when I worked on Travel
Channel that got away from me cuz I was
you'd go out like three weeks in a row
and that's when I'd get weird like like
legit I started doing this thing called
what will the maid think it was what do
you mean so one day I'm in San Antonio
and I'm leaving my hotel room for the
day and I look at my room and all I see
on the nightstand are six Heinekens a
towel and lotion and immediately I'm
like the maids gonna come in and be like
oh great last night was date night wish
I I don't I guess I'm doing the cleanup
for it yeah yeah and so I thought
instead of cleaning out what if I left
something kind of like a red herring to
throw her off like something so
distracting that she would just focus on
that so I put we have a picture if I put
an ironing board yeah
wait here's a toilet yeah yeah right
okay so she comes in the room and then
she just focused on that what the hell
happened in this room so I come home
that night right this is the best
toilets left exactly the same way I go
to the bedside table and there's a towel
monkey and brand-new lotion I go
we got a gamer I like this right so then
when I check out this what I do I take
my shirt and a pillow and I put my shirt
over the pillow and I shove it in the
refrigerator so it looks like a torso in
there you have way too much time on your
hands
hipster heavily tipped are heavily but
then I knew she was gonna come in and
look for it and be like damn you didn't
leave anything go to clean out the
fridge and go holy [ __ ] so and then I
started doing that everywhere I went and
it literally I became obsessed with it
we have pictures and I'll walk you
through them there this one is that
blood no it's ketchup and and those are
all the towels that they gave me so I
couldn't shower for the rest of the week
that one was in New York the next one
let's see where this one was oh this is
my this is my take my wife please yeah
it is brilliant in its simplicity its
snow outside I'm across the street from
the West Edmonton Mall I was so proud of
that one whatever stick around and watch
their reactions okay what oh my god this
may be my favorite so far oh you haven't
seen my best one yet okay this is when I
started getting out of control when I
would get manic and I this was two
separate ones and then I was like oh
they're too good together
so it's like an et as the lamp and then
those are my teams in my shoes right
that I had to leave behind but yeah what
you sacrificed your clothing so I
sacrificed everything gotcha I became so
into this you have no idea I would be up
just drinking whiskey in the middle of
the night going you can do better Burke
you can do better okay let's take a look
I think we have right here this is when
I had to draw the line because what was
happening is the hotels were finding out
about it and they were elite they get
there and they're like oh it's him it's
him we left you a lot of stuff in your
room and they would leave me like 20
towels six pillows just and then there'd
be like five maids at the door knocking
going did you do it yet I was like
that's too much pressure
oh it became way too much pressure and
it was like I was literally spinning out
of control like Howard Hughes just
looking at things with that lamp looks
like a dog yeah yeah I think you had one
last one is that right is there one left
we have one more that I think there was
one last one there we go here we go yeah
I like that one that's right we did that
in San Francisco they all have like a
little piece of my heart although your
your biceps don't look like
[Laughter]